-Michael B. Jordan!
-Man, I love coming here, man.
I love it.
-Come on. You feel that...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You feel that love?!
Do you feel it? Come on.
-I love it, I love it,
I love it, I love it.
-They love you, buddy.
-I love coming here, man.
This is a
great, great spot, man.
-Well, we love having you here.
You're hosting
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yes, sir.
-How's it going, bud?
-It's going great.
I literally just left,
you know, rehearsal just now,
going through the blocking
and stuff like that.
And it's a machine.
And they are so fantastic and
great at what they do.
It's been a great process.
-Can you talk to me about
the pillow?
-Oh, yeah, the pillow.
Okay, so,
I walk into the office.
And they're like,
"Alright, this might be weird.
This might be a little weird.
We actually have been
living with you
for the last 10 years."
I said, "Living with me
the last 10 years?
What are you talking about?"
They're just like, "Well --"
It was one of the producer's
birthday, and it was --
one of the other employees
there got her a pillow, right?
And it was a life-sized,
almost like a pregnancy pillow
of me printed on both sides.
And I'm like, "Wait.
You guys had this for how long?"
It's been there for 10 years.
It's been there for a decade.
-You brought us a photo.
-I got a photo of it.
And I'm like, "Wait a second."
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, I'm like,
"So, wait, wait, wait."
I said, "Whose pillow is that?"
And, you know, the lady was
like, "Oh, it's mine."
And she was like, "Listen,
our hours here are so crazy,
everybody takes naps, you know,
at some point during the day."
-Of course.
-I was like, "So wait.
Every lady in here has slept
with me at some point
over the last 10 years?"
-That's exactly right.
-And they were like,
"Yes, actually, everybody has,
at one point."
-That's exactly right.
Yeah, why not?
-That was cool.
-I've got to say,
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
came out.
There were rumors --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was fantastic.
-Thank you, thank you.
-There was rumors,
are you going to be in it?
Are you not going to be in it?
And when I saw you
in interviews, you were like,
"I am not in this at all."
If you have seen it
or plan on seeing it,
maybe just mute your TV
for a second.
You are in it.
-Yeah, I am in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And it was great.
-Thank you, thank you.
-It was awesome.
How hard is it
to keep that secret?
-It's tough, you know?
I think, this time around,
you know,
because we lost our brother
Chadwick, you know --
Rest in peace to
Chadwick Boseman.
And it was so much weight
and so much just
trying to power through,
you know?
And Ryan Coogler
had such, you know,
a tremendous task in front of
him to evolve the script
and the story in a way that
still kind of honored Chadwick,
but move the franchise
forward, as well.
So for me to be able to
come back, you know,
and I had to really keep it
under wraps, you know?
I had to grow my hair out.
You know, I got the locks back
in and stuff like that.
And, you know,
I'm traveling a lot of places,
so I've got to, you know,
wear a hat, a hoodie, you know,
fly private,
which isn't too bad of a thing.
But being able to keep it under
wraps was really a tough thing.
-Were you doing "Creed III"
at the same time?
-Yeah, we were both shooting
down in Atlanta
at the same time.
So that made it
a little bit easier
to be able to bounce around
from studios.
But it was a hard thing
to keep under wraps.
-How do you do -- First of all,
you're not only starring in
"Creed III," you produced it,and
this is -- you directed it.
-Mm-hmm.
-This is your directorial debut.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You crushed it.
-Thank you.
-You crushed it, buddy.
-Thank you, man, thank you.
-How do you like
directing yourself?
-I love it.
You know, it's --
-You get along with yourself?
-Yeah, just a little bit.
-I mean, the lead actor's
a bit of an ass[bleep]
but, you know, it's cool,
you know?
You know, we got through it.
-Eventually, you got the
performance out of him, yeah.
What's it like directing
with gloves on?
-It's tough.
You know, you're -- You know,
you've got a mouthpiece
in sometimes.
You got gloves.
You're always depending on
so many people.
Your team is everything,
you know?
So, to be able to be in
the middle of a boxing scene,
honestly, it's sometimes easier,
because I can direct
while I'm acting.
You know, if I needed to move
you upstage a little bit,
I just move
a little bit like this
and then I get the shot
that I need,
'cause I'm already -- I'm kind
of I'm low-key cheating,
'cause I'm, like, editing while
I'm actually acting
a little bit.
-Yeah, all of a sudden, you just
start moving around the scene.
Wow, yeah,
you're finding your light.
-So, it's -- Yeah,
so it was fun. It was fun.
-Did you get to talk to any
other directors beforehand?
-Reached out to
a lot of directors.
You know, I'm blessed to have,
you know,
Denzel Washington, Ryan Coogler,
Steven Caple, Jon Favreau,
Bradley Cooper, you know?
Like, I reached out to, like,
the community of directors,
and everybody gave me
great advice.
And one of the greatest advices
I got was from
Bradley Cooper and Jon Favreau.
They was basically like,
"Get your first shot off
as quickly as possible."
Like, it's one of the --
it's one of the --
It can slow down
your entire day.
You know, if you don't get that
first shot off very early,
you're probably not
going to make your day.
So as soon as you get it off,
the train is rolling
and the machine just won't stop,
so you'll more than likely
get more shots than you --
-I love that advice.
-Yeah.
-That's good.
-Thank you.
-You know, I watch
these movies and I go,
"There's no way
they can make the shots
look different
in a boxing ring."
You did it again.
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
-It's something else -- It feels
like you're in the ring.
Like, I've never --
Again, I've seen, you know,
the "Rockys,"
I've seen the "Creeds."
But what was the -- This thing
was, like -- It's insane.
You actually see
skin flapping and blob.
I go -- How did you
change the game again?
-We were just --
You know, I think I got --
It was a gift
and a curse, you know?
There's been, you know,
eight other movies before me,
you know?
And we've shot --
You can shoot a boxing match
so many different ways.
I think 'cause I was
kind of put in a corner,
it kind of forced me to be more
creative and really find --
like, think outside the box
of how to make
the fights different.
So we shot
all the fights in IMAX.
And, also, I had a huge
Japanese anime influence
on a lot of my fighters.
I'm an anime nerd, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I found unique ways to
kind of -- Exactly.
Yeah, you --
-And then -- Dude, it was --
-The thing and the thing?
Okay, alright.
-Yeah. But I watched as a fan.
I'm just enjoying.
You put the work in, man.
-Yes, sir.
-I was like,
"Oh, it was great."
Jonathan Majors, by the way,
is who you go up against.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dude...
-My brother is incredible, man.
-Dude is jacked in this movie.
-Yes, he is.
-Both of you guys are.
-My man's in shape.
I thought, you --
I go, "Oh, my God.
That's Michael B. Jordan."
Then he shows --
Get ready, 'cause he shows up,
and I'm like, "Wow!"
-He is in the most insane shape
that I've ever seen.
And we needed somebody that was
going to be, you know,
an antagonist,
but somebody intimidating.
We wanted to make Adonis
feel like an underdog.
So when you see Jonathan Majors,
he looks like he can
beat the crap out of whoever.
-Yeah.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, and he
plays it perfectly,
'cause you feel for him
and then you don't.
Then you -- He's a punk.
-You know, I mean --
-Then you're like,
I want you to win, you know?
-I think it's more interesting
to have, like,
an antagonist
that has depth to him.
Like, he's not just a,
you know, twirl the mustache,
"Ha, ha, I'm a bad guy."
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
-You've got to understand, you
know, why he is the way he is.
-It was well done.
-Thank you.
-How do we set this up,
"Creed III"?
-"Creed III."
I think it's about, you know,
you can't really outrun
your past.
You know, you have to kind of
like, look inward to,
you know, to -- And you have to
face your demons
in order to move forward
in life.
You know, you can't just
keep moving forward
without actually reflecting.
I think, you know,
childhood trauma,
those transformative years,
things that you've been through,
you have to face those
things in order to
have the courage to
move forward to do new things.
And I think that's
a big part of our film.
-And Adonis Creed sees someone
from his past that was --
It was one of his old buddies.
And he just returns
and he is trouble, man.
-He's trouble.
-He turns Adonis' world
upside down,
and he has to kind of
move backwards to move forward.
-Checkmate.
-My man.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Ooh! Checkmate.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Michael B. Jordan
in "Creed III."
Take a look at this.
-Hey, my man.
Can I help you?
-Let me get an autograph?
-No, I ain't signing
no autographs,
but you get off of my car.
-Old homie.
You don't remember me, huh?
Come a long way from
bummin' rides from your mom.
-Dame.
Whew! Boy, you had --
you had -- you had me.
-[ Laughs ]
-Damian.
-Yeah, just got back
to the hood.
Stopped by the old gym,
but, uh --
-Yeah, we upgraded
a couple years ago.
-I see.
-Damn, it's -- it's, uh --
-It's been a minute.
-Been a minute.
-Whoo!
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael B. Jordan!
"Creed III" is in theaters
and IMAX March 3rd.
Michael is hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend with musical guest
Lil Baby.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.